ocho millones trescientos mil personas
es casi un 20 por ciento de la población
de ucrania y es la previsión del éxodo
ucraniano para este año hasta ahora la
guerra desarraigado a más de 12 millones
700 mil personas sólo en los últimos 2
meses de las cuales más de 5 millones
han huido como refugiadas fuera del país
y siete millones setecientos mil
permanecen como desplazadas internas el
bastión industrial de que barry tierra
natal del presidente volodymyr selenski
se ha convertido en un polo de acogida
para esos desplazados internos
fundamentalmente para los que huyen de
gerson
no tengo a dónde más ir estoy aquí con
mi hermana
no digan que está bien volver a casa
álvarez donde pongo yo
polonia es el país que acoge la mayor
cantidad de refugiados que salieron de
ucrania casi tres millones de personas y
las autoridades aseguran que han tratado
de hacerlo de la forma más humana
posible
no tenemos ni un campo de refugiados la
idea fue persuadir a los polacos a abrir
sus hogares y sus corazones a los
vecinos ucranianos
holmes / hearts
davis
en rumanía los refugiados ucranianos han
comenzado a organizarse para recibir a
sus compatriotas que siguen llegando y
en irlanda la integración pasa por
aprender un nuevo idioma
estoy estudiando inglés porque quiero
integrarme a la comunidad irlandesa y
ser capaz de socializar soy una persona
muy sociable y me siento sola si no
puedo hacerme entender o sencillamente
dar las gracias por lo que la gente está
haciendo por mí
[Música]
mientras las necesidades por el éxodo
siguen creciendo europa y los países de
acogida se enfrentan al desafío de
integrar a los refugiados a su nueva
vida